Harry Styles hilariously trades places  with James Corden have you been working  out  [Music]  they're holding Pirates of the Caribbean  for ransom sounds to me like they're  charging them an arm and a peg on  Tuesday's episode of The Late Late Show  the 23 year old singer epically stood in  for the late-night host while he  pretended to be Harry in this  over-the-top getup tattoos and all you  are you look amazing  thanks very much just a little something  I threw together what about these bad  boys when the two switched back harry  performed another one of his new hits  the sign of the time singer whose new  self-titled album is number one in 83  countries kicked off his week-long  residency on the show with Corden on  Monday and teased a much-anticipated  carpool karaoke segment that will air  Thursday  [Music]